as of three days ago i believe it would
have been the great steve irwin's 60th
birthday correct me if i'm wrong
absolutely so
what does he mean to you what does steve
irwin mean to tarzan he means everything
to all of us you know especially people
in my field of work
he just he gave us uh uh
he took a cartoon which was like a
tarzan or a mowgli or a jungle book and
he made it in real life you know and it
was like wow i used to watch
old school
black and white tarzan movies from like
the 20s 30s or whatever they put them
out 60s i can't remember but
you know and seeing jungle book and like
wow it's a cartoon it's dope you know i
want to be like that but then seeing
someone like see where we're going like
oh [ __ ] right like you're not actually
ladies you know who steve irwin is right
i can't put a let's see david come on
i can't tell you i'm pretty sure i know
him i just cannot put his name in the
face together right
yeah
can you do your best
maybe a video david or something
um
yeah so he is the goat so what again
what does he mean to you what has he
done to i mean he's my biggest
inspiration man you know he inspires all
these kids including myself to love
animals you know if anybody loved a dog
or a cat or a bird or snake like myself
and you've seen this guy you want to be
just like him and nothing else nothing
else mattered you know you don't want to
be a nba player or a movie star you want
to be steve irwin you want
if i could have shook his hand i'd cut
my arm off and framed it that's how much
steve irwin means to a person like
myself you know but you can ask someone
that would go their whole life dribbling
a basketball and then finally you know
humans are very rare
he's your michael jordan he's your
muhammad ali that's probably the best
way to put it exactly let's watch this
clip of the great steeler one it's game
over
game over
and a big salty can easily hide in
shallow murky water
an offal in and around the water and
that creates a free feed for the
crocodile
these bullet shells are a result of the
fishermen getting scared they see a croc
they think it's stalking them boom they
take a pot shot at it i'm here to help
humans but also protect the crocodile
like
the goat
what's his background like how did he um
develop into this in the tv world same
thing in his family i think his mom and
his dad were heavily in the animal
conservation animal rescuing in
australia and um he just became a part
of it just being born into these i think
his uh
his father had a
zoo as well too and his mom also had
some type of sanctuary or
rescue she was a part of and of course
they made steve irwin and then he grew
up in the same australia is also built
different there's just animals oh my god
everywhere you gotta get with the
program if you live in australia yeah if
you're automatically australian you're
already about that life you have to but
being with a mom and dad both in that
same you know field of work and
lifestyle and then having a kid like
steve
you you just bread the goat
so so i remember watching steve irwin as
a teenager and it was it was
it's basically jackass but not for
idiots like for people that want to do
stuff for the environment and animals
and learn it but the stuff that he was
doing was
beyond intense and he's
basically
influenced you know he was the original
influencer we talked about how mike's
social influence now but he was the
original investor before social media
who comes to mind that has
that he has influence obviously you but
who else is out there that's like okay
it's me
it's his kids man okay his kids have
picked up the torch from where he left
off and carried it amazingly i mean like
it's just he's got a son and a daughter
his son just spit an image of him man i
watch his son on instagram on tv i'm
like dude i'm re-watching the goat like
the goat had a baby goat and they're
very good it's growing up can we see a
picture of him david uh it's amazing
it's it's so cool it's so it's a
beautiful thing to watch
robert irwin you know
have you met the family i would love to
one day i'm sure like that's something
that's sure i'm sure they'd love to meet
you for some someone that talks that
highly about i would cry if i met them
you know it's like you know you can't
i i don't even want to go there really
you know
it means that yeah exactly so his kids
have picked up with a legacy yeah that's
left off for sure anybody else out there
that comes to mind that you work with or
some major influencers lots of people
out there who comes to mind uh dr evan
dr evan anthony i think he's on animal
planet as well just great work you know
for animals
um who else uh damien aspinall uh the
aspen asthma foundation they work with
gorillas you know they re wow gorillas
steve went to go visit them you know
some years back made a video there and
stuff but just you know these people are
you connected to a non-profit or you
have your own yeah i have my own i'm
connected to a bunch of them you know we
love to help and do anything we can for
what's the name of your non-profit let's
put in the link below so we can uh make
sure that it gets
wildlife foundation corporation so it's
basically just regular wildlife but it's
spelled w-y-l-d
[Music]